we may have to pay more for ps5 in
series X Games Capcom doesn't want you
to call the new Resident Evil Resident
Evil 8 and Ubisoft reveals its new
battle royale
I'm chastity and you've reached your
save save for Thursday July 2nd we've
been used to spending $60 on games for a
while now including the ones that we
play once and fully intend on finishing
but never do which I've done plenty of
times but get ready for that feeling to
hurt a little bit more in the future
because PS 5 and series X games may cost
$70 $60 has been the standard us game
price for a long time now but that might
change with next-gen consoles the first
instance of this is NBA 2k 21 it's the
regular $60 on ps4 and Xbox one but $70
on PS 5 and series X furthermore the
$100 momma forever Edition is the only
one that includes a next-gen upgrade
this gets more complex when you consider
Microsoft's smart delivery feature which
will let you buy any first party Xbox
game and get the next gen upgrade for
free third party dubs can decide for
themselves if their games will allow
this
for example cyberpunk 2077 is a third
party game that has a free upgrade so
none of this means that $70 is the new
norm but if this game is successful you
can imagine other companies will do the
same thing I'm pretty excited about the
new Resident Evil and just FYI the
official title is Resident Evil Village
not Resident Evil 8 despite the Resident
Evil Village trailer highlighting the
villain village to make the Roman
numeral 8 Capcom doesn't want us to call
it Resident Evil 8 officially the name
is just Resident Evil village because
Capcom is trying to focus on the game's
new setting producer CEO Shi Conda and
Peter Fabiano told Famitsu quote you
could call the actual village another
character in the game and we did that
because we would like players to
understand that so they hope that fans
call it re village and not re 8 but
that's not gonna stop us the game is
coming to PS 5 series X and PC in 2021
you play as Ethan winters the
protagonist from Resident Evil 7 and
village will be the conclusion of his
story also Chris Redfield is back and
there are werewolves so
get high if you're tired of the same old
battle Royales and you want something
new Ubisoft revealed its battle royale
called hyper scape hyper scape was
teased earlier this week and now it's
been officially revealed it's a battle
royale game with its own spin on a lot
of things when you loot a weapon you can
loot the same weapon again to upgrade it
your characters don't start the match
with abilities you loot these on the map
- and they're called hacks when you die
you turn invisible and you can still
move around on the map and spot enemies
for your teammates when a few squads are
left a crown spawns pick it up and hold
onto it for forty-five seconds without
dying and you'll win the match without
having to defeat every other team it's
set in a futuristic city so instead of a
shrinking circle districts get blocked
off one by one
also there's twitch integrations so
viewers can vote on things like allowing
triple jumps and unlimited ammo hyper
scape is currently in technical test on
PC and we've got plenty of gameplay info
and impressions on GameSpot and if you
don't know by now game spots play for
all is still going strong we're raising
money for black lives matter and kovat
19 Direct Relief and we've got special
charity streams every day at 12 p.m.
Pacific time we've got some great guests
lined up tomorrow we have Chris Pratt
from people make games and next week
don't miss Skyrim mods with cam and said
on Tuesday I'll be putting Jack Pattillo
and the GameSpot team to the test with
movie trivia so don't miss that check
the links in the description below for
more information and come hang out and
help us raise money for a good cause and
that's your save save for Thursday I'm
chastity and you can find me on Twitter
and if you like movies and TV check out
the podcast that I host called you
should be watching it's on all podcast
apps so check it out and Curt will be
back on Monday with more news see you
next time
you
[Music]